this week you know
Adam 22 is showing why we need to start
shaming people that disrespect marriage
this is disrespectful so you know I
tweeted and I'd like to say adam22 I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you guys a
background on Adam so I went on Adam's
podcast about six months ago maybe eight
months ago I didn't really have a
problem with Adam I was super sick on
this interview I oh my gosh that is like
the sickest I have been in the longest
time I was so sick the whole interview I
was just trying not to die
and so it was kind of a mild interview
honestly and it was fine we did the
interview and then I I moved on whatever
and a couple months later
he calls me a misogynist and all of his
hosts are talking about me and I'm
thinking Adam
I thought we were Pat and it's such a
weird phenomenon where like you'll know
someone and then they go I mean I'm like
all right whatever
fair play
fair play I'm like all right
I I see how this is so the atom 22 and
Lena comes out I'm like fine
you want to call me a misogynist let's
talk about the real misogyny you pimping
out your wife
and so I actually I had this thought
yesterday where I was thinking we I
interview all these only fans models and
guys you have to understand I I do this
I I talk to them all the time even my
producers are starting to realize like
patterns with these chicks none of them
ever have a plan if they have a plan
it's like real estate or going into like
production but none of them have really
accomplished anything
and they they basically are just they
have a hard time dating they'll tell you
they have a hard time dating and even if
you survey men most would eliminate a
woman as a long-term Prospect if she's
done only fans
and so really like what what are what is
society gonna do with all these old
they're not going to settle
um they're not gonna
um they're not gonna settle they're not
gonna
go down and die so what's really gonna
happen because they're not gonna get the
men that they want
um and so I tweeted and this wasn't even
about Adam anymore that's funny thing
what do we do with these only fans
once they're broke horse that no
one wants to marry in 15 years so I
tweet that right and Adam Adam comes
back at me and says no offense but you
should be more worried about nobody
wanting to marry you right now you know
um and I just thought it was so
interesting because I said your
definition of marriage is letting
another dude bang your wife on camera
people like you are ruining the sanctity
of marriage it's an insult to people
that take marriage seriously
and I really I really believe this I
really believe that true marriage is
between two virgins I believe some
non-virgins get lucky and you know
they're in a society where that stuff's
accepted but I really think it's true
marriage but now now we're getting to
the point
where literal and I'm not even
you know I know sometimes I'll be like
guys two bodies it's more for
definition purposes but
you know now now we're getting to the
point where literal prostitutes are are
getting rings and we all know it's not
gonna work out and he says I'm a happily
married dude with children you're an
unwed sinner with no suitors you will
die alone in a bingo hall
you know fair enough and so I just give
my take you know I didn't know marriage
was cucking out your wife at the expense
of your children if that's what marriage
is I'd rather die alone I swear to do I
would rather I would rather be by myself
with cats then do what Adam is doing
I I would rather that's what I'll pick I
I pick the cats over a dude over your
your husband the guy that's supposed to
protect you cucking you out with porn
stars really
um and and my question genuine question
why do you get married why do people
like you get married why insult
religious people by making a mockery of
the sacrament guys if I'm being honest
like I I think marriage is such a holy
sacrament that barely anybody deserves
it keyword deserves some people get it
because of God's grace but I really I
really think rarely people actually
deserve marriage and so my question and
you know the people that do get married
that have had crazy pasts they at least
put it aside and and start something new
and beautiful but what you're seeing
with with him really is making them all
like they could have did this before
they got married but it's like then why
get married if God isn't at the center
it's it's supposed to be a religious
Sacrament with God that's that's what
marriage is and you you could see the
wording he says we got married because
we plan on spending the rest of our
lives together and you can tell how sure
he is of the relationship because it's a
plan
it's not what it's not what they're
gonna do
if it offends religious people that's a
huge Plus for me so that's off awesome
to hear you know and I I have to be
honest guys like you know that would be
like me imagine me and I I don't really
know like I I don't I'm not too familiar
with the Islamic like what they do with
the mosque but I'll give you an example
right
so when I was like 18 my family we went
to uh I was like 18 19. we went to I
can't remember where I think it was like
Abu Dhabi or somewhere in the Middle
East and we all went as a family a super
fun trip and
um I remember we went into like one of
the mosques and you had to put on
um the like I don't know what they're
called the hair covering stuff and you
know my my mom and my dad really
explained to me that you are in someone
else's like religious uh place you're in
another country you need to follow their
rules these are their rules and so you
know I so we did and there wasn't you
know a question but people like this
it's like they're playing pretend
they're pretending to be married they're
pretending to be a husband and wife but
really it's just two porn stars putting
on a show
um and I think that's offensive the same
way I think it would be really offensive
for me to go and and do some Jewish
traditions and like Islamic Traditions
uh without actually walking the walk you
know again I'm not really too familiar
but it's like I'm a Catholic so I'll
give you an example from a catholic's
point of view you know we we take
communion really seriously and people
and you have to get your first communion
um
first like you have to go through that
Sacrament and I I think it's it'd be
really disrespectful for someone to be
you know claimed to be a Catholic by in
doing this this porn stuff or like you
know using that Sacrament and you know
like imagine if oh my gosh I can't even
oh this like makes me sick to think
about but role playing that in a like a
sex scene I think that's gross I think
that's wrong and I think it's it's wrong
to the people that actually take
marriage seriously
um and so I said it's actually people
like this that need to be shamed out of
marriage they ruined it for the people
that actually believe in marriage and
that's what you got a lot of fake wives
a lot of fake wives that don't believe
in submission a lot of fake wives that
Nag on their husbands constantly a lot
of fake wives that give their kids to
daycare instead of raising them a lot of
fake wives that don't cook for their
family a lot of fake wives that really
Bamboozled their husband that have these
crazy paths that they didn't tell their
husbands about and you know it's one
thing to come in with like humility
right and I and I've you know I think
the most women I wouldn't advise men to
go for women with a past pretty much
ever because we just yeah but you know
the women that do make changes and men
too right they come in with some
humility but it's like this arrogance
and this this deserving that I can't
stand I really think very few people
deserve marriage I think very few people
walk the walk to be honest in 2023 I
think have a very toxic society and it
is incredibly offensive that we have
people role-playing marriage without
submitting to their husband without you
know dressing modestly it's like then
why get married in the first place so
and I said it's actually disgusting that
you set out to offend religious people
that take marriage seriously to
Sacrament Adam a promise to God and you
know notice he says we plan on spending
the rest of our lives together instead
of we will he says Pearl chooses
podcasting and tweeting over getting
married and starting a family
fortunately she'll have Candy Crush and
a bunch of cats to come for her with old
old age
so I respond I said at least I didn't
choose porn over marriage at a family
like your wife I mean that's the choice
is that different and you know what the
funny thing is I used to work in
Corporate America do you know what my
life was like before this I have a
hundred percent control over my schedule
I get to work from home before I worked
in you know miserable that was copier
sales
oh my gosh this is amazing I'm so tired
of podcasters acting like we're just
these godsends because we talk for a
living we talk and tweet and that's why
I say you know podcasting really is easy
influencers just like to cry and whine
about it the worst part about adam22 is
what he promotes is actually going to
leave these women miserable you know I
interview only fans models all the time
they have zero savings zero plans and
zero dating prospects if this goes
south they have no backup plan and Adam
will sell them a dream that women
like his wife you know can get a happy
outcome and some will I'm not even
saying none will but a lot won't and for
everyone that does there's ten that
don't and as women we always think we're
special in the exception and the truth
is most of us are average and normal
what do you what do you think a man has
to make to afford a housewife
probably like
uh
she wants a Range Rover she's not just a
normal house
[Music]
all right so 100K 100K so what percent
of guys do you think make 100k
he's like
10 to 15 yeah you're right roughly well
I mean I don't remember these like 10
yeah something like that I I don't know
100K here is higher I'm thinking U.S
terms but it's probably like eight but
okay close enough right so what age do
you think that men make that much money
oh between that and boy
55 that's in companies
so so you think a guy works to 55 to get
a housewife and in return he wants her
to go shopping in his Range Rover and
gets nothing in return because I didn't
hear anything you do for him well he
would he would get me as his wife okay
so you're telling me a guy that worked
he made it to 55 worked his whole life
busted like these men have hard jobs
they bust their ass to get there okay
most men aren't gonna make that right
yeah and in return
get sex that he could get from any
oh and he gets a trophy wife in it like
he gets a wife that you can say look my
wife's sexy Circa tuned in um zurco's
been on the channel for end of the show
Pearl reads studies and offends you with
the studies these aren't these are not
her opinions you are mad at the studies
that remind you of your future being
like everyone else in the west a
disaster yeah that's true
um you know women that have slept with
more than five men have a very low
marital satisfaction rate it is what it
is and you know
um
really the odds are not for us the women
of the West the odds are against us even
if they don't have that the the media is
against them all marketing does and guys
you could you could I could sell you a
dream and tell you the future's bright
but right now it's not I I hope it
changes
um but I really don't see it happening
until they switch this system and we
stop having people role play and pretend
I think we need to get the government
out of marriage it needs to go just to
religious institutions who need to vet
people very thoroughly before giving
them like really guys
you know marriage marriage is a gift
and it's not deserved it's given to us
by God and if you don't follow God like
it I just think it makes a mockery out
of the whole thing I think it's really
offensive
and this is and it all connects guys
everything connects the legal system
connects the marriage system connects
um to the way men and women interact
today
um feminists have ruined a lot but let
me know what you guys think in the
comments uh maybe Pearl's just a crazy
old lady you know old old Pearl just
working so hard tweeting just tweet
tweet tweet
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time